good afternoon since you've just had a
museum tour about the liberal media
we're now going to talk about this we're
not going to talk to the future of
conservative radio okay so there there
as as you will see if you're not seen
before there are four floors the kirby
center the first floors are floor for
students classrooms computer space
there's even a small gym space the
students request the second floor is our
public for where we've all been meeting
today or Washington and Lincoln parlours
the third floor has offices including
the Churchill room which is also dr.
Oren's office when he is here to visit
and then we have this floor our library
floor which overlooks the US Capitol
very close proximity which now houses
the boil radio studio immediately behind
me Bayer and hoodie boil are from
Memphis Tennessee two of the most
delightful people you would ever meet
Baird was in the commercial building
business for many years and is still in
the investment business and that success
allowed them to be great philanthropists
including to support hillsdale college
they were unable to join us today
unfortunately but I have to say how
grateful I am personally for their long
friendship and commitment to my work and
how grateful we are for the continuing
support of Hillsdale College they
dedicated the studio to an esteemed
family friend dr. Paul Tudor Jones and
their own son Paul Tudor Jones Boyle who
is named after that dear friend of
theirs so thank you Baird and honey oil
this studio will be linked up with a
broadcasting studio on the main campus
in Hillsdale Michigan which is now the
home of a radio station w RF h radio
free hillsdale that station and these
studios are part of a new and unique
Hillsdale program to train students in
broadcast journalism the inspiration in
driving force for that effort who was
instrumental in getting our radio
licensed on campus and providing for all
the radio equipment here in this studio
and on campus and in providing the know
how to create and operate these
facilities was Vince Benedetto Vince is
a graduate the Air Force Academy and
served in the Air Force with distinction
and he now is in the radio business he
has nine stations in Pennsylvania and
New York under his bold gold Media Group
and before I asked him to come up I
would like to recognize two people with
him Bob Vander Heidi where's Bob / he's
standing and hiding in the corner who's
the bold gold coo and today he'll be
running the boards for our inaugural
broadcast and also the bull gold
business manager ashok de vecchi did I
get it close enough is that with that
good
but please join me in thanking vents and
asking him to join us to say a few words
Vince
oh my well this is quite terrifying to
speak before a national radio talk show
host and dr. Arnn is not a position that
you want to be in very often we're going
to talk a little bit about radio for a
few minutes and why we are so excited to
support this project at bold gold I want
to thank my entire bogle media group
team and they've been very instrumental
in helping complete this project the the
amount of prep work and planning and an
installation involved in thinking
through all the engineering and
technical issues could not have been
done without without my great staff at
bold gold media group I also want to
thank my bowl gold broadcast media
foundation team and they've been very
helpful in guiding as well and I do want
to acknowledge David Madeira morning
show hosts of scranton/wilkes-barre is
only 24 7 conservative talk station who
has been a tireless on-air proponent of
radio and conservative talk radio in our
market so David thank you
so you know why radio why is it so
important and why do we love it so much
I think it was at Thomas Jefferson who
said I cannot live without radio books
I'd like to think though that you know
radio is really the modern-day town hall
in so many ways right it is it is where
people gather and they talk and they
listen and they debate and I think it's
remarkable to note how conservatism has
thrived in the broadcast radio sphere so
well we're in other mediums television
print Hollywood those it's not thrive
there and i would put forth that some of
that is authenticity radio is often
called the original social media it's
live it's engaging it's relevant that's
local and everybody's experience with
radio is unique and it's a mass reach
medium but when somebody is listening to
radio they're in their car they're at
their dinner table at the breakfast
table there at the gym and they develop
a relationship with the host whether
it's a local host or national host and
that's that relationship is powerful the
other thing that radio has and i would
put forth that this is why it thrives
and conservative thought and ideas
thrive on radio is think about a typical
radio interview when you listen to mr.
Hewitt's show listen to the level of
detail and dialogue and discussion that
he can get into there it really is a
powerful medium for education whereas
television very powerful as well as pro
more to sound bites and visuals I would
argue that truth prevails on radio so
well because it will be discovered if it
is untruthful and that is why liberal
talk shows don't make it
you know and here's the thing here's why
we're so excited out this program right
is it's extremely important that talk
radio grow well into the future and as a
mutual friend of mr. Hewitt and mine
Phil boys will point out radio has no
bench particularly talk radio the
industry is involved in a way that there
aren't a lot of young people getting
into this medium and what's great about
radio and I'll give you an update
because people ask me a lot about the
future of the media Nielsen just came
out with a study about two weeks ago
it's very reason ninety-three percent of
Americans in a typical week tune into a
broadcast radio station seventy percent
in a typical day it's now surpassed
television as the largest mass meech
mass reach medium it's alive and well
and but radio now is not just on air as
we like to say in bold gold it's on air
online mobile social live and local and
radio reaches people in so many
different ways and influences people in
so many different ways and we're big
believers in bold gold that to get other
young people to tune in to radio and
particularly talk radio we need more
young people in the media and so this is
where the relationship with Hillsdale to
help support this broadcast program and
I think has such a unique opportunity I
can think of no other place where
student can go learn the things that
they learn at a college like Hillsdale
learn about the Constitution and
concurrently learn broadcast
broadcasting and I think that's very
powerful and this will be the place
where those young people can go people
that want to follow in the footsteps of
a Hugh Hewitt or Mark Levin this would
be the only logical place to go and so
it's it's going to be a profound and
powerful thing I just real quick to
explain that the broader program dr.
Spalding touched on a little bit so
there is a new campus radio station in
Michigan and 10 1.7 fmw rfh and of
course a studio out there and this
studio here will have three purposes
essentially one is
we'll be able to connect to the studio
in Michigan so that events happening
here the students in the program will be
able to broadcast live on air at the
main campus and so if you have a speaker
Ryan for example coming here to give a
dress that can be actually put on air
live in Michigan second it will serve as
a visiting remote broadcast studio for
visiting radio hosts like it's doing
today and third it will be a place where
the faculty and students visiting here
at the Kirby and working here at the
Kirby can produce high end audio for
later use later broadcast and streaming
podcasting and whatnot so very powerful
facility here that they will have in in
closing I just want to congratulate the
college on taking this most important
step in the future of radio I have no
doubt that them talk radio has a bright
bright future with the likes of
Hillsdale getting into the business of
training young people in the medium and
we're very excited at bol gold and Vogel
Media Group to be supporting those
efforts in any way we can so thank you
for joining us today
Thank You Vincent thank you again for
your your great support and especially
of the work or i should say the work of
the fellows you brought with you who do
the real work getting all this figured
out the line about jefferson by the way
that was what Franklin tweeted there
there's a man would have they have the
new technology as vince mentioned one of
the reasons for the studio is to allow
some of our friends to broadcast from
the kirby center and so they can say
they're broadcasting from Hillsdale
College in Washington DC right here near
the US Capitol and one of our best
friends is hosting our inaugural radio
broadcast which is going to go live at
starting at six o'clock with dr. Oren
and a few other guests that we're going
to be coming by this evening he's a
lawyer and law professor quite learned
the author a dozen books and his
nationally syndicated radio show is
heard by more than two million listeners
every week on in more than 120 cities so
please join me in joining suit me join
me in welcoming mr. Hewitt
thank you Matt first let me thank Vince
for having it work it worked beautifully
we did an hour long dry run before you
arrived with an interview with Senator
Ted Cruz and a four segments interview
with Morton kondracki and Fred Barnes on
their new book about Jack Kemp in the
second hour of today's show will feature
United States Senator Tom cotton who I
think is a future United States
President will be here and he'll be
followed by the Speaker of the House of
Representatives Paul Ryan who will be
here at the kirby center so you will see
that Vince's work and your support of
the kirby center has already brought
people here and ideas to this space into
this center to show them that Hillsdale
College is more than what i call the
lighthouse of the north it is in fact
the lantern of the capital as well as
the lantern in the north but i want to
tell you briefly how it came to be that
i will broadcast here just for a little
texture we had some made-up quotes my
favorite quote is dis raleys and dis
raleys is a majority is better than the
best rep parte what he did not say
though is that reppert a sometimes has
to precede a majority and I wonder what
would Churchill have been that's for dr.
Arnn to say without the radio what would
Churchill have been without BBC and I
would ask you what would FDR have been
without the radio what would Ronald
Reagan have been without the radio all
three of those extraordinary
communicators use the radio so I have
loved being in radio all these years
because it has the one thing that
broadcast medium does not allow you
anymore which is time we have time lots
of time so 25 years ago when my hair was
brown and I just moved to California
after leaving the Reagan administration
I was introduced to dr. arm by our
mutual friend the late wonderful Tom
Fuentes at a Coco's nothing nearly this
posh the studio has its own bathroom
Coco's didn't have a bathroom so I'm
very impressed with with that 25 years
we've done from Coco's in Mission Viejo
to the hillsdale kirby center 20 years
ago i met penny and penny is integral to
this story in a way that not many of you
will know but i will remind dr. Arnn
about in just a
and 15 years ago i started my nationally
syndicated show on the salem radio
network which is a little bit ahead
events but started in the same way that
Vince began by a young man in that case
I dad singer and his brethren lost to a
person buying one then four then ten
radio stations and building a network
that is now 120 and that's what Vince is
about as you start with one and use the
profits to build another one and you
expand it so Vince's really recreating
what the platform I inherited 15 years
ago so i started doing three hours a day
ten years ago I called up larry aaron
who was then the president of hillsdale
college and i said i'd like you to do
the history of ideas in two days with me
and he said that can't be done that's a
stupid idea you have many stupid ideas
you and and by the way this is how he
speaks to me in front of a hundred
million people each week and and it's
charming it's actually charming it's
worked quite well when we showed up in
Arizona with John last year and there
were 11 hundred people to hear Larry or
and I talked about the Constitution I
was amazed and it ified and gratified
but it's because of that Rep parte that
we share on the radio so ten years ago
we did a six hour special which airs
every New Year's Eve in New Year's Day a
history of ideas in six hours and it's
available at hue for Hillsdale calm and
hillsdale dot edu so five years ago I
got a harebrained idea and because it
was so far-fetched I was glad that penny
was in the room because penny is the the
anchor the common sense and if she
blesses it then I'm I got a runway here
so we SAT Larry and Penny down and I
said I think Larry ought to do an hour
radio week either with a professor or by
himself or in combination thereof and
that we begin with homer and we keep
going till we're done and then we start
over and do it again and that became the
Hillsdale dialogues of which there are
now about 150 hours of them available at
you for Hillsdale dot-com or Hillsdale
dot edu and you can binge listen and
they become a cult following such that
if I miss a week my audience is mad at
me that larry aaron has not been on the
radio or
even Smith or any of them I try not to
mention any of the Hillsdale professors
because if I mentioned one and you don't
mention them all are you suggesting I'm
not as good as them and their their
academics I'm an academic I know what
that means but dr. Arnn comes on and so
we have marched from Homer right now
we're going through the new book
Churchill's trial that Larry is authored
and people tuned in and they're edified
they are uplifted they're educated and
it's an amazing thing I have been
teaching out of lynn Cheney's new book
on madison these past weeks and i just
finished chapter 7 which is the
Constitutional Convention and Madison I
did I didn't alright forgotten this
perhaps Larry taught it to me and I'd
forgotten at some point got quite angry
the Constitutional Convention on
occasion because he would lose arguments
he would lose arguments over the nature
of the executive he would lose arguments
over the representation of the states in
the upper chamber he would lose a lot
area but he would win some arguments and
he would never give up and he'd come
back and argue some more and I think
part of the poverty of American ideas
today is that there aren't any arguments
and there aren't any places to have
arguments so that when you watch that
Hindenburg of a debate last week that
was not a debate and Larry and I did
eight weeks a setup week and then a week
/ lincoln-douglas debate each one of
which was three hours long between two
people without a moderator they're
probably the best seven hours of radio
I've ever done I know what Larry thought
about him but they were remarkable
because these exchanges were arguments
that extended for three hours in front
of ordinary Americans about whom we
often think snootily in the media that
they don't care they're too stupid they
don't have time they don't want to hear
it they do they listen to good radio
they listen to good conversation so to
Vincent to all of you for supporting
Hillsdale realize that the studio
tonight and every day that it operates
them coming back friday i'm an interview
peggy noonan from here i know if she's
coming in studio or not we'll do it
whenever I'm in town this is where I'm
going to broadcast from if it's
available and as soon as people see that
it's as nice as at it I'm going to be
fighting off Levin who's on marks one of
my oldest and dearest friend and he's
going to want to come here he's going to
any all that people from here and
I got it done been hearing it and hear
it since 1992 so so he's gonna get in
Larry's your head yeah let's do it you
guys it yet didn't you and and whether
it's rush or anybody what a wonderful
thing for the students to see and to
have the engagement so I'm very grateful
to be a partner with hillsdale college
and that they care about this medium and
that they're going to raise up a new
generation with Vince's help on the
campus in here so that when I'm 59 and
the bench is very very thin I'm one of
the young guys that's the bestest sad
thing I get preggers a hard time about
that but whether it's Dennis or Michael
all of us we have a few years left and
by that time we'll have hillsdale's
young cadre marching forward thanks to
the work of dr. and Penny aren't penny
was the one who green-lighted the
hillsdale dialogues by the way that's
why I brought her up she thought that
was a pretty good idea and I remember
that so thank you all for being here
Matthew
I want to thank pin yarn for the
Hillsdale dialogues which are which are
absolutely wonderful and thank you with
you for that if radio was around the
time of the American Founding and there
was someone who would sit an interview
Madison and Hamilton to be Hewitt that
would have been done done wonders for
the cause and it is a wonderful show to
offer a few remarks will have a more
formal introduction later today but to
offer a few remarks and offer a toast to
dedicate our studio formally I give you
the president hillsdale college Larry
so I want to assign blame I blame matt
for the activity level here and how much
trouble it was I set out to run a little
liberal arts college and I got this big
mess on my hands I blame Vince Vince
comes to me and he says I'm going to get
you a low-power radio license Radio Free
hillsdale it is now and it's not going
to be any trouble you and it's not going
to cost you any money and I said wow
that's the stupidest idea I've ever
heard in my life and he said why i said
well gosh you don't know anything about
the college business to you for example
the students write a newspaper the thing
is a pain you know they write whatever
they want to in it there's they're very
interested in me and now you're going to
put them on the radio and and John
Miller sitting in the room said well we
can have a seven-second delay that's
gonna rescue the situation in it well we
got that thing going now and God knows
what's going to happen and then you I
blame you you know Vince is that I also
thank Vince because it hasn't been any
trouble to me and i'm amazed about that
and you know the students have not
really started broadcasting yet so i'm
holding on but he is Vince is a very
remarkable man you should get to know
Vince he's nothing but good but I do
blame finally Hugh I think this idea you
said you need a radio studio in there
you know and I said to somebody we need
you says we need a radio studio in there
and then Vince comes along and says well
I'll put one in there for you and and
you know by arden hoodie boil and I want
to say something about them because
Matt's claiming some authority over them
and he may have known them longer than I
have it they're going to watch a tape of
this thing but the truth is I
grew up in Northeast Arkansas and they
live in memphis tennessee and mad is
this West Coast boy right so how can
they even like him whereas the first
time I met him you know Memphis was the
big city you went to if you went to
Arkansas State University and I didn't
mention many of the places that I had
been to in the city to buy yard because
they would know where they were anyway
there are deer people right and they
inventive helped us put this thing
together and it's going to roll it's
going to be a great thing and I'll tell
you the reason for that the reason is
love everything happens for love
everything bad I'm teaching you
Aristotle now in case you want to know
him in case you don't either everything
bad happens because of a mistake about
love what is the love students have to
learn to use their noggins their noggins
are the essential thing about them
they're the reason that they're free
they're noggins involve thinking and
they involve talking and thinking and
talking are the same thing when you are
talking you are thinking out loud and
when you are thinking you are talking to
yourself it is through talking that you
know the good of things else you would
never yet have ever voice too common now
you must think through I'm not going to
explain it to you today this is too
short and I'm assigning blame today I'm
not going to explain it to you but it's
true that every time you you can name a
comment down and you can't make a single
sentence without the use of one you are
naming the good in everything the being
and the good of each thing being what
makes it what it is and the same thing
and through this magic we become social
moral and political first two pages of
Aristotle's ethics and politics both
begin with that argument
students have learned think but they
have to learn to talk because skill at
the two are not exactly identical
although the faculty is the same so
there are people we have a new cork
horse coming in next year and hillsdale
college the core is the horror of the
student body and the reason they become
great and they all do watch the Arizona
Cardinals and the Oakland Raiders star
Jared Veldheer and star Andre Holmes
hillsdale college graduates and they
graduated during the years when three of
our young men who clerked on the Supreme
Court also graduated and half the time
those two boys and those three boys were
taken the same courses and the next one
to be added is called rhetoric and logic
and those are not redundant one of them
is skill in using your noggin and the
other skill in stating what you have
concluded and you require both when we
dedicated Radio Free hillsdale the other
day because Vince is coming at me in an
avalanche of radio right now as Hugh has
always done what else do I blame you for
by the way it is true that since I met
you 25 years ago is that what you said
about that yeah he's asked me to do a
series of things that are impossible and
and they have some have been kind of
done his specific is a specific request
of me was we're going to do 30
philosophers and I you know I I'd love
to tell the story of the first graduates
couldn't school class I ever had in the
wisest words I ever heard which were by
Harry Jaffa a very great man and he said
life is too short to ever read a hundred
books I have a list of the three great
books life is long enough that if you
work hard at it you might learn three
books and he held up the Nicomachean
ethics which I teach at Hillsdale
College down said this is one of my
books
is a great book you know so I learned
that way right so now I'm gonna do 30
books and I have done them and it would
have been impossible without you and I
thank him for that as well as blame him
been a big influence on my life in
various ways good and good but back to
my argument what why would we need both
rhetoric and logic today logic there's a
fellow that sits on the Supreme Court
right now the best of them and he was
asked repeatedly in his hearings where
did you get the curious idea of the
natural law and he did not mention to
them that it is in the first sentence of
the Declaration of Independence the
place where the country that these
people supposedly serve was built right
I know that fella he said to me one time
I bet you didn't think I gave a very
good answer and he's I said what do you
think he was being kind right if we lost
touch with the central thing is that not
evidence for it and the evidence is also
everywhere and then if you could think
all that through you wouldn't fall in
love with it you know to learn the
language in which the freedom of man is
stated is to learn a thing of compelling
beauty and to learn it is to fight for
it you fall in love with it you will
defend it and so it's not learning that
right and then the second thing is if
you can learn what it is you should
learn to say it and it is written in
very beautiful words and so you just
have to get the cadence in you and so
that's what we try to do at Hillsdale
College for every single student who
comes there and because we do
it for them which is hard you know
because they're all smart and they could
all go somewhere easier and warmer and
and somewhere that will give them better
grades you know because we won't and we
tell them that before they come and then
they show up you see and what happens it
turns into joy and then they learn to
talk and then through teaching them we
also learn to talk and then we can talk
to the country if you just think back to
the first college which was founded by
Plato in a wall and I in a field outside
the walls of Athens the field given by a
man named academic owes from which we
get the term the Academy if you think
about the revolutionary impact that that
thing just some conversations you see
had when they radiated around the world
to make one of the two component parts
of the West of which we are part and
from which and through which we enjoy
our freedom and claim the freedom of
every human being see that means that
the strongest force on earth is the love
of the good and the true and the
beautiful and in that we find our
freedom and our civilization now you
know what's going to be on our radio
station thank you